imagine you're having conversation with
your friends now at some point in this
conversation someone's going to bring up
crypto currencies now crypto currencies
is something that everyone wants to talk
about but no one really knows how they
work so today I'm going to fix that
I am route from simply learn and this is
crypto currency explained since man
world currency has been a very important
part of our lives in the caveman era
they use the barter system now the
barter system involves goods and
services being exchanged among each
other so now we have a situation where a
caveman is exchanging seven apples and
getting oranges in return
now the barter system fell out of use
because it had some glaring flaws
now these flaws include having people's
requirements coincide for example say
you have Phi apples and your friend has
five oranges you want some of his
oranges now until and unless your friend
has a requirement for the apples that
you own he'll not be ready to make an
exchange for it there's no common
measure of value now since there's no
common measure in terms of which value
of a commodity can be expressed there's
a problem when you have to decide how
many apples you are ready to trade for
one orange or a mango not all codes can
be divided or subdivided for example you
can divide a live animal into different
smaller units the goods cannot be
transported easily now unlike our modern
currency fits in your wallet or your
mobile phone the goods that you own
cannot be taken with you everywhere you
go after realizing that the barter
system then work very well
currency went through a few iterations
in 110 BC an official currency was
minted in thousand 250 AD gold plated
Florence was introduced and this was
used across Europe and from 1680 to 1980
paper currency gained widespread
popularity and was used across the world
this is how modern currency as we know
it came into existence modern currency
included paper currency and coins credit
cards and digital wallets for example
you have Apple pay Amazon pay pay DM Pay
Pal and so on all of this was controlled
by banks and governments now this means
that there was a centralized regulatory
authority the delimited how paper
currency and credit cards worked now
imagine the scenario of doing an online
transaction here you're thanking your
friend for paying for your lunch are you
saying that you're sending the money to
their account now this transaction takes
place successfully but there are several
ways where this could have gone wrong
they could have been a technical issue
at the bank for example the systems
could have been
the machines weren't working properly
and so on that means there's a central
point of failure which is the bank the
users accounts could have gotten hacked
for example they could have been a DDoS
attack or identity theft and so on or
the transfer limits for that account
were exceeded this is why the future of
currency lies with cryptocurrency now
imagine the transaction between two
people in the future one of them has the
Bitcoin app and there's a notification
asking whether they sure they're ready
to transfer five bitcoins if yes
processing takes place here we're
authenticating the users identity
checking whether they have the required
balance to make that transaction and
other things now after that's done the
payment is transferred and the payment
is received all of this happens in the
matter of minutes and is as simple as
that
this in turn removes all the problems of
modern banking there's no limits to the
funds you can transfer your accounts
cannot be hacked and there's no central
point of failure now as of 2018 there's
more than 1,600 cryptocurrencies
available now there are some popular
ones like Bitcoin litecoin it's Harry
amends each cash and a new
cryptocurrency crops up every single day
now considering how much growth they're
having at the moment there's a good
chance there's plenty more to come in
the upcoming years so what exactly is
cryptocurrency a cryptocurrency is a
digital or virtual currency that is
meant to be a medium of exchange
now cryptocurrency is quite similar to
real-world currency just that it does
not have any physical embodiment it also
uses cryptography to work the way it
does now some of the features of
cryptocurrency are that there's a limit
to how many units can exist with Bitcoin
this limit exists at 21 million now
after this no more bitcoins will be
produced you can easily verify the
transfer of funds now the hashing
algorithms that Bitcoin uses makes it
very easy for users to determine whether
a transaction is valid or not they
operate independent of a bank or a
central authority they work in a
decentralized manner now new units can
be added only after certain conditions
are met for example for Bitcoin only
after block has been added to the
blockchain will the miner be rewarded
with bitcoins and this is the only way
new bitcoins can be generated so what
makes cryptocurrency so special firstly
there's little to no transaction costs
now if you use the digital wallet you'll
know that if you're transferring money
from your wallet to your bank account
you lose some amount of money you have
24/7 access to money you can't just walk
up to your bank at 3 a.m.
morning and say that you want to
withdraw some money there's no limits on
purchases and Madras there's freedom for
anyone to use for example if you are
setting up an account in your bank you
need to do some amount of paperwork and
documentation with cryptocurrencies all
of that can be avoided international
transactions are faster the wire
transfers take about half a day to
transfer money from one place to another
but with cryptocurrencies
it only takes a matter of minutes or
seconds what's the crypto in
cryptocurrencies
crypto navistick or Prague Rafi it's a
method of using encryption and
decryption to secure communication in
the presence of third parties with ill
intent now this refers to third parties
who want to steal your data or want to
eavesdrop on your conversation
cryptography uses computational
algorithms like sha-256 which is the
hashing algorithm that Bitcoin uses a
public key which is like a digital
identity of the user with he shares with
everyone and a private key which is a
digital signature of the user which he
keeps hidden now let's talk about a
normal Bitcoin transaction first you
have the transaction details now this
details who you want to send it to and
how much bitcoins you want to send them
then it's passed through a hashing
algorithm for Bitcoin we use the sha-256
algorithm the output that you obtain is
passed through a signature algorithm
with the users private key now this is
used to uniquely identify the user this
output is then distributed across the
network for people to verify this is
done by using the sender's public key
the people who verify the transaction to
check whether it's valid or not unknown
as - now after this is done the
transaction and several others are added
to the blockchain where it cannot be
changed again if the concepts of hashing
seem a little difficult to you I would
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch the blockchain explain
video so that you can understand better
now the sha-256 algorithm like I told
you earlier looks something like this
now seeing how complicated it looks i'm
sure it's safe to say that the
encryption is very difficult to hack
today we will be focusing on two major
crypto currencies Bitcoin and ether now
bitcoin is a digital currency that is
decentralized and works on the
blockchain technology it uses a
peer-to-peer network to perform
transactions let's talk about ether
ether is a currency that's accepted in
the etherium Network now the etherium
network uses blockchain technology to
create an open-source platform for
building and deploying decentralized
applications now let's talk about the
similarities
VidCon and ether they are the biggest
and most valuable cryptocurrencies in
the market right now both of them use
blockchain technology which is nothing
but a technology that involves
transactions being added to a container
called bloc and creating a chain of
blocks in which data cannot be altered
currency is mine using a method called
proof-of-work which is a form of
mathematical puzzle that needs to be
solved before a block can be added to
the blockchain finally these are widely
used across the world now let's talk
about the differences with Bitcoin it is
used to send money to someone this is
very similar to how real-life currency
works with ether it is used as a
currency within the etherium Network
although it can be used for real-life
transactions as well Bitcoin
transactions are manual which means you
have to personally perform these
transactions with ether you have the
option to make these transactions manual
or automatic or programmable which means
that these transactions will take place
when a certain conditions been met for
Bitcoin it takes 10 minutes to perform a
transaction which is the amount of time
it takes for a block to be added to the
blockchain with ether it takes about 20
seconds to do a transaction no
blockchain is used like money for real
my transactions and ether is used to
power the etherium network and power
real-life transactions as well ether is
used as fuel within the etherium network
to power both of these things now there
is a limit to how many bitcoins can
exist which is 21 million we supposed to
hit this number by the year 2140
ether is expected to be around for a
while but not to exceed 100 million
units the Bitcoin is used for
transactions involving goods and
services and ether uses blockchain
technology to create a ledger to trigger
a transaction when a certain condition
is met for Bitcoin we use an algorithm
called associate 256 for hashing and
with a theorem we use eg hash as of July
23rd 2018 one Bitcoin equals seven
thousand six hundred sixty eight dollars
for ether it costs four hundred and
sixty four dollars now what's the future
of cryptocurrencies
the whole world is clearly divided when
it comes to cryptocurrencies
on one side you have supporters like
Bill Gates Al Gore and Richard Branson
who say that cryptocurrencies are better
than regular currencies on the other
side we have people completely against
it people like Warren Buffet Paul
Krugman and Richard Schiller who are
both Nobel Prize winners in the field of
economics they call it a Ponzi scheme
and means for criminal
in the future there's going to be a
conflict between regulation and
anonymity since several cryptocurrencies
have been linked with terrorist attacks
governments would want to regulate how
cryptocurrencies work on the other hand
the main emphasis of cryptocurrencies
is to ensure that their users are kept
anonymous by the year 2030
cryptocurrencies would occupy 25% of
national currencies which means the
significant chunk of the world would
start believing in cryptocurrency as a
mode of transaction it's going to be
increasingly accepted by merchants and
customers and it will continue to have a
volatile nature which means prices will
continue to fluctuate like they have
been for the last few years with that
we've reached the end of another video I
hope you guys found this informative and
helpful if you have any feedback or
doubts put them down in the comments
below we'll be happy to help you thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from simpler hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here